[Музика]
добре, хлопці, ласкаво просимо назад, і ми продовжуємо
говорити про роботу та кар'єру, хлопці, чи
ви коли-небудь були на співбесіді про роботу
одного дня, можливо, вам доведеться
піти, але чому, можливо, вам точно
доведеться піти так  давайте здобудемо нові навички,
як поводитися на вашому першому або, можливо,
наступному співбесіді в якості підготовки,
давайте підберемо людей до їхніх ситуацій,
тож давайте прочитаємо ситуації та
відкинемо їх
давайте візьмемо Майк Майк не проти стресу
, насправді це допомагає йому працювати  краще добре
який хороший працівник, він краще працює
зі стресом, тоді приходить
Джулі Джулі завжди сидить за своїм
столом, коли всі інші приходять в
офіс, уявіть, що люди просто заходять
в офіс, а Джулі вже
там наступна, яку Хуліо хоче стати головою
одного дня його компанії
голова означає, що бос номер чотири Дейв
майже ніколи не робить помилок, він двічі
перевіряє всі свої розрахунки, щоб двічі
перевірити, означає перевірити ще раз, а
потім, можливо, ще раз
і ще раз w  Ну, це гарна ідея не
робити помилок наступного, що
Берті продовжує робити ті самі дурні
помилки, хм, навпаки, Дейв,
наприклад, вона часто неправильно пише
імена клієнтів у своїх електронних листах,
помилки означають, що вона пише ці імена
неправильно, а остання Карло
завжди підтримує своїх колег  і
приймає їх поради, тому він дуже
підтримує і добре, він приймає їх
поради, давайте подивимося, тому ми змогли
працювати в команді, здатній працювати під
тиском,
амбітний, обережний, необережний і пунктуальний,
добре, тому ви повинні відповідати цим
рисам характеру  людей та їхні
ситуації подивіться, дайте їм 30
секунд і порівняйте їх добре, хлопці, ви
готові перевірити, тож ось відповіді,
перша з яких Майк добре
справляється зі стресом, це означає, що він
здатний працювати над тиском,
а потім приходить  Джулі та Джулі справді
пунктуальні, вона вчасно приходить на роботу,
потім приходить Хуліо, і його амбіції, його
амбіції – стати босом своєї
компанії, а потім голова, потім приходить примадонна  і
Дейв обережний, він все перевіряє,
і це дійсно обережно,
а навпаки, недбало, а
Берті необережний, вона неправильно пише імена клієнтів,
і останній Карло, він
може працювати в команді, тому що він слухає
своїх колег і підтримує  вони добре,
хлопці, гарні риси характеру, чи є у
вас щось із цього, чи ви обережні, чи ви
амбітні, чи здатні ви працювати
під час стресу, чи ви пунктуальні, якщо ви є,
то у вас точно не буде
проблем під час співбесіди, давайте
продовжимо, ось робота
поради щодо співбесіди подивіться на них, і ви
повинні подумати, чи є вони гарною порадою чи
ні, і тому першим я
шукаю нові виклики, якщо ви використовуєте цю
фразу під час співбесіди, ви
вирішите, що я справді нервую,
якщо ви покажете  ваш потенціал для
вашого майбутнього роботодавця, що ви
нервуєте, і якщо вам прямо сказати, що я
дуже нервую на вашому співбесіді,
наступна фраза, скільки я зароблю,
звичайно, це справжня  цікавить,
яка зарплата, але чи варто задавати таке
пряме запитання своєму роботодавцю
наступне в короткостроковій перспективі, я хочу
розвинути свої навички продажів і отримати більше
досвіду в хорошому продажу, це
здається гарним реченням, звичайно, про яке ви
говорите  твої плани, можливо, це
хороша порада наступна моя слабкість полягає в
тому, що я працюю занадто важко,
що означає занадто важко, так що це твоя
слабкість, що ти працюєш занадто важко, або
тобі варто це використати, подумай про
наступну роботу.  показує
твій ентузіазм, але все-таки можна
на співбесіді сказати, що мені справді потрібна
ця робота, будь ласка, дайте мені цю роботу, можливо,
не
добре номер 7 Я досить добре працюю під
тиском Я вважаю, що дуже
мотивує працювати над тиском, це хороша
навичка  і ви вказуєте причину, чому це
добре, можливо, це гарна порада
наступний мій нинішній бос
жахливий добре, якщо ви збережете це своєму
майбутньому роботодавцю, що ваш нинішній бос
- це лише біда для вас,
ви вирішите, потім прийде ні я не  Мають
до вас якісь запитання на
співбесіді, ваші майбутні роботодавці
хочуть, щоб ви задали їм кілька запитань,
тому що ви повинні показати, що ви
зацікавлені в компанії, тож, можливо, у вас
повинні бути запитання, і останнє мені
подобається ідея безкоштовного  закуски в п'ятницю,
безкоштовні закуски, вони, безперечно,
гарні, але чи можна проявляти таку
зацікавленість у закусках, але не в
компанії, добре,
подумайте трохи і виберіть ті, які, на вашу
думку, не підходять для співбесіди,
і дозвольте мені показати вам свою  цього
разу всі відповіді правильні,
так що я думаю, що недобре
говорити, що ви справді нервуєте, тому що
тоді ви показуєте, що ви не настільки
впевнені в собі, не варто просто запитувати,
скільки я зароблю,
безумовно, вам потрібно домовитися, але
не будьте такими прямолінійними, наступна
моя слабкість полягає в тому, що я занадто багато працюю,
безумовно, роботодавці хочуть мати
працьовитих працівників, працьовитих
працівників, але якщо ви приходите на роботу, і
ви не думаєте, що т  o працюйте дуже наполегливо,
навіщо ви їм потрібен наступний. Мені
дійсно потрібна ця робота, це
здається дуже відчайдушною фразою, і коли ви
відчуваєте себе відчайдушно, ви показуєте свою слабкість
у своєму житті, ви завжди повинні мати
план плану B і плану C і там
більше інших літер в алфавіті
наступна мій нинішній бос жахливий,
навіть якщо це правда, навіть якщо твій
бос катастрофа, це не кей обговорювати його
чи її з майбутнім роботодавцем, тоді
я знаю, що у мене немає жодних питань  для вас,
якщо ви скажете цю фразу на
співбесіді, ви показуєте, що ви не
зацікавлені в компанії, ви повинні провести
дослідження, перш ніж йти на
співбесіду, і ви повинні задати кілька
питань, і останнє я люблю
ідеальний безкоштовний  закуски по п'ятницях знову
закуски - це просто добре, але не
радійте перевагам і перевагам перед
закусками, краще підкресліть деякі хороші та
позитивні сторони самої компанії, а не
лише закуски добре, я хотів би, щоб ви
записали ці фрази, тому що  ти будеш н  Використовуйте
їх під час читання, тому я даю вам одну
хвилину, щоб записати фрази червоним кольором,
чи не могли б ви розмістити
фрази, хлопці, чи готові ви
продовжити читання, тому ви вже зробили це завдання
один раз, перш ніж це дуже легке завдання, тому що
іноді вам не потрібно  щоб прочитати
весь абзац, навіть щоб отримати уявлення,
іноді потрібно зрозуміти кілька
слів і D, і вони будуть правильними
відповідями, ви матимете таке завдання під
час зовнішнього іспиту, і ці
завдання економлять час в реальному часі, ви можете отримати
свої бали, а не витрачати  надто багато часу
на них,
цього разу ми спочатку прочитаємо весь текст,
а потім поговоримо про
відповіді, поговоримо про
початок цього параграфа, заголовки
, це речення, які я просив вас
написати, і вони були  речення червоним кольором
Я сподіваюся, що ви це зробили, якщо
ви цього не зробили, поверніться
до відео і зробіть це добре, тож давайте
почнемо читати ніколи не кажіть те, що на
співбесіді, ось сім речей, які ви
ніколи не повинні робити  y на співбесіді, якщо
ви не знаєте свою потенційну зарплату,
не варто запитувати про це на початку
співбесіди, якщо ви зробите це, інтерв'юер
подумає, що вас цікавлять лише
гроші, і нічого іншого
роботодавці хочуть людей, які добре
підходять  для позиції про те, що вони
пропонують переговори про зарплату, слід
дочекатися кінця співбесіди, компанії
не хочуть наймати когось, хто не
має жодної впевненості, тому не завжди
добре бути чесним, якщо ви нервуєте
, намагайтеся не показувати цього  якщо
інтерв’юер попросив
вас побачити ваші слабкі сторони, ви не повинні
відповідати стандартною відповіддю, яка
звучить як прихована сила,
досвідчені інтерв’юери знають цю хитрість,
замість цього розкажіть роботодавцю про реальну
слабкість, але свідок, який не настільки
важливий для роботи
, не варто  згадайте, наскільки вам подобаються
деякі переваги компанії, такі як безкоштовні
закуски, інтерв’юер подумає, що
ви не дбаєте про успіх
компанії, намагайтеся не показувати, що ви
відчайдушні  відчай від роботи – це
ознака слабкості. Ніколи не критикуйте
колишнього керівника або компанію, це некласно,
і це змусить вас звучати негативно,
коли інтерв’юер запитає, чи є у вас якісь
запитання, не кажіть ні, це змусить вас
виглядати неготовими до співбесіди або  мене не
цікавить робота чи компанія,
добре, хлопці, це був досить легкий текст для
читання, і я думаю, що у нас не буде
проблем із назвами абзаців, тому давайте
почнемо з першого, першим
має бути скільки я зароблю та
фраза  це показує нам, що це
правильний початок, насправді це слово
зарплата означає суму грошей,
яку ви отримуєте від свого роботодавця, і
це правильна відповідь, друга,
пам’ятайте, що мова йде про впевненість і
знову нервування, відповідь дійсно
проста, і це  я справді
нервую, тому не витрачайте свій час, якщо ви
побачите очевидні відповіді, просто введіть їх
і продовжуйте нормально, номер три номер
три, щоб інтерв’юер міг запитати вас
про ми
nessus  але ти хочеш їх приховати, і
ти вкладаєш як приховану силу, а це
недобре, тому в чому була прихована сила,
і це була моя слабкість, це те, що я працюю
занадто важко
, це прихована сила, ти сказав, що
ти працюєш занадто важко, але насправді ти просто
хочеш  щоб похизуватися, можливо, наступний я
люблю ідею безкоштовних закусок по
п'ятницях, це гарна ідея, але це
не ідея успіху компанії, яку
найбільше цікавить роботодавець,
я п'ятий, мені дуже потрібна ця робота, якщо
ви  скажіть цю фразу, оскільки це сумно, ви
показуєте свій відчай, і ви не
повинні впадати у відчай насправді, тоді приходить номер
шість ніколи не критикуйте боса, і
це початок, як мій теперішній бос
жахливий, не будь грубим, це не класно
і останній  ні, я не маю
до вас жодних запитань, будь ласка, будьте готові задати
кілька запитань наприкінці
співбесіди своєму роботодавцю, щоб показати, що
ви дійсно зацікавлені в компанії
добре, хлопці,
гарні підказки, і тепер ви готові
вислухати  інтерв'ю ар
добре, і ось запитання на співбесіді,
тож, будь ласка,
перегляньте всі запитання, це
питання, які ви можете почути під час
співбесіди, і всі вони реальні,
тому перше, як би ви описали
себе, подумайте та дайте відповідь  у
своїй голові або ви можете використати свій зошит
і записати його, можливо, друге
запитання, чи не могли б ви сказати мені, на кого ви працюєте
на даний момент, це означає, що ви
повинні сказати назву вашої нинішньої компанії, на
яку ви працюєте, і це
чудово  згадайте свою компанію, в якій ви
працюєте зараз, і тому, що ви там робите, і
насправді, які ваші сильні сторони і
чому ви можете бути дуже успішними як
працівник у новій
компанії наступного разу, як довго ви
працюєте, тому коли люди читають  ваше резюме,
тоді вони побачать, що ви
працюєте в різних компаніях протягом
тривалого періоду часу, можливо, вам не варто
брехати, ви не повинні говорити, що ви працюєте
три роки на когось, але насправді
ви працювали лише три місяці  через кілька секунд, тоді
виникає питання, чому ви хочете працювати в цій
компанії, так, вони хочуть знати вашу
мотивацію, і це не нормально говорити,
що я хочу отримати більше грошей, тому що,
ймовірно, це причина, але
не розкривайте свої приховані інтереси,
добре  наступний чому ви залишаєте
роботу і знову не потрапляйте в пастку і не кажіть,
що мій бос жахливий, не знайдіть
кращої причини, чому ви хочете
змінити роботу, наступний, що ви можете
запропонувати нашій компанії, так, дуже гарний, якщо
хочете  мати хорошу зарплату, якщо ви
хочете мати кращу роботу, скажіть, чому
ви кращі. Наступна, як ви знаєте, ця
робота вимагає багато подорожей, це
проблема для деяких людей, які
багато подорожують, це може бути проблемою,
тому що вони  у вас є сім’ї, і вони
не можуть покинути свої домівки, але для деяких
людей це може бути корисним, якщо у вас
був досвід у цьому, означає, чи працювали ви
з чимось, чи ви щось пробували,
наступне – це ваші
цілі на майбутнє  дуже поширене
питання, тому g  які ваші цілі
на майбутнє перша мета, звичайно
, закінчити школу, а потім прийняти рішення про
свою майбутню кар'єру, або ви можете вирішити
свою майбутню кар'єру зараз, і тільки потім
закінчити школу залежить від вас, потім
з'явиться ваша найбільша слабкість  дуже
складне питання, ви не можете приховати свої
сильні сторони дуже очевидно, тому що вони
це побачать, але ви все одно повинні говорити
про свої слабкості, якщо ви
усвідомлюєте свою слабкість,
якщо ви знаєте свої слабкі сторони, тоді ви
знаєте, де вам, де вам потрібно працювати
краще і  що ти маєш змінити
можливо наступний як ти справляєшся з
тиском як ти справляєшся з тиском
добре як ти працюєш під стресом чи можеш
ти працювати під тиском чи ти не
вмієш і ти просто залишаєш добре наступний
що ти селера  вимоги це
означає, скільки ви хочете заробляти, добре зараз
, ви б послухали це інтерв'ю, і
ви повинні послухати запитання
, які будуть задавати дівчині, добре, тому
запишіть номери
qu  що ви чуєте добре, ви
готові слухати добре, так що слухайте, будь ласка,
доброго ранку, міс Медора, будь ласка, сідайте
доброго ранку, мені приємно познайомитися, чи
не могли б ви розповісти мені, на кого ви
зараз працюєте так, я працюю на KP Lewis
як  давно ви працюєте у них
я працюю в KP Louis протягом
останніх трьох років і скільки часу
ви працюєте в
бухгалтерії я працюю в
бухгалтерії останні вісім місяців і чому
ви залишаєте роботу  Чесно кажучи, я
відчуваю, що не можу використовувати всі свої навички на
своїй поточній роботі, і посада, яка
часто виглядала як чудова для
мене, ви знаєте, що ця робота вимагає багато
подорожей, це проблема для вас
ні, ні, це не  насправді проблема мені
дуже подобається подорожувати, і я не
маю сім'ї, про яку можна доглядати, тож добре,
чи був у вас досвід у продажах, так,
як видно з мого резюме, я працював неповний
робочий день представником мовної
школи, яку вони пропонували  якась мова
курси, і мені довелося відвідувати різні
агенції, це цікаво, наскільки
ви успішні, школа, в якій я
працював, зуміла збільшити кількість
записів у результаті моєї
співпраці, дуже цікаво,
тому які ваші цілі на майбутнє
добре в короткостроковій перспективі я хочу розвивати свою
навички продажів та отримати більше досвіду в
продажах у довгостроковій перспективі. Я хотів би
отримати високу посаду в такій дорослій
компанії, як ваша, і скажіть мені, яка
ваша найбільша слабкість, добре я визнаю, що маю
тенденцію чекати до останньої хвилини,
щоб призначити зустрічі, але я  Я покращуюся
в цьому, і нещодавно я зрозумів, що
планування заздалегідь має більший сенс,
як ви справляєтеся з тиском насправді я
досить добре працюю під тиском Я вважаю, що це
дуже мотивує, і це допомагає мені зосередитися на
тому, що я маю зробити, добре  хлопці, я сподіваюся,
що ви почули всі запитання, давайте
перевіримо ваші відповіді тут, вони в порядку,
тому питання, згадані в інтерв'ю,
є питанням номер два, чи не могли б ви сказати
мені, на кого ви працюєте  t на момент
питання номер три як довго
ви працюєте над питанням номер п'ять
чому ви залишаєте роботу питання
номер сьоме ви знаєте, що ця робота
вимагає багато подорожей полягає в тому, що для
вас проблема номер вісім чи
був у вас досвід  в і
питання номер дев'ять,
які ваші цілі номер десять ваша
найбільша слабкість і номер одинадцять,
як ви впораєтеся з тиском добре
ось питання, зараз я попрошу вас
послухати його вдруге, тому що
вам доведеться мати справу з кількома
виборами  питання давайте подивимося на них,
можливо, ви вже знаєте деякі відповіді,
тож перше,
скільки часу Кейт працює на Cape
ill use, і у вас є варіанти:
три роки чотири роки або вісім
років наступне, скільки вона
Працює в бухгалтерії
бухгалтер - це той, хто працює з
цифрами і веде бухгалтерію, тож три
місяці чотири місяці або вісім
місяців,
то чому вона л?  входить на
роботу, їй погано платять,
ви не можете використовувати всі її навички, і її
бос жахливий, добре, давайте подивимося, що
наступна подорож – проблема для неї Так
Ні, можливо, тоді чому вона була успішною
як торговий представник у мовній
школі, тому що  школа збільшила свій
прибуток, тому це означає, що школа отримала більше
грошей, школа продала більше книг або
школа збільшила кількість реєстрацій, це означає, що
до них прийшло більше людей, наступні
запитання: які ваші короткострокові
цілі на майбутнє вона хоче купити
будинок  вона хоче розвинути ваші навички продажів,
вона хоче стати менеджером.
Ну, один варіант здається дуже
особистим, вона хоче купити
дійсно особистий будинок, тому чи варто говорити
про це під час співбесіди, можливо,
не наступне, що для неї довго-  довгострокові
цілі довгострокові дівчата означає, що триває
кілька тридцяти років, а не лише один рік,
це може бути як десятиліття, десять років, тому вона
хоче отримати високу посаду в
компанії, це означає, що вона амбітна, тоді
вона хоче  розпочати власний бізнес,
який досить амбітний, тому вона
хоче працювати в школі, ми побачимо
наступну,
що ваша найбільша слабкість, вона
занадто багато працює, вона перфекціоніст, і
вона призначає зустрічі в останню хвилину,
і це те, що останній  спонукає
її зосередитися на вашій роботі тиск на роботу в команді
хороша зарплата іноді хороша
зарплата є хорошою мотивацією, але для деяких
інших людей робота в команді може бути хорошою
мотивацією зараз, будь ласка,
послухайте це слухання ще раз і відзначте
свої відповіді доброго ранку, міс Медора
будь ласка, сідайте доброго ранку, мені
приємно познайомитися з вами, не могли б ви розповісти мені, на
кого ви працюєте
так, я працюю на KP Lewis, як
довго ви працюєте в них, я
працюю в KP Louis протягом останніх трьох
років і  скільки часу ти працюєш
у бухгалтерії. Я
працюю в бухгалтерії останні вісім
місяців і чому ти залишаєш
роботу, чесно кажучи, я відчуваю, що не можу
використовувати всі свої навички на своїй  поточна робота
і посада, що він часто виглядав
як чудовий для мене, ви знаєте, що ця
робота вимагає багато подорожей, це
проблема для вас
ні, ні, це не проблема, насправді мені
дуже подобається подорожувати, і я не
маю сім'ї  доглядати за тим, що добре,
чи був у вас досвід у продажах так, як
ви бачите з мого резюме,
я працював неповний робочий день
представником мовної школи, вони пропонували
деякі мовні курси, і мені довелося відвідувати
різні агенції, цікаво,
наскільки успішними були  ви добре, школа, в якій
я працював, зуміла збільшити кількість
реєстрацій у результаті моєї
співпраці, дуже цікаво, тому
які ваші цілі на майбутнє, а в
короткостроковій перспективі я хочу розвинути свої
навички продажів і знову більше досвіду в
продажу в довгостроковій перспективі.  мені подобається
отримати високу посаду в такій дорослій
компанії, як ваша, і скажіть мені, яка
ваша найбільша слабкість. Я визнаю, що маю
тенденцію чекати до останньої хвилини,
щоб призначити зустрічі, але я готовий  ну,
і я відразу зрозумів, що
планування заздалегідь має більший сенс,
як ви справляєтеся з тиском насправді я
досить добре працюю під тиском, я вважаю, що це
дуже мотивує і допомагає мені зосередитися на
тому, що мені потрібно зробити, хлопці, ви
готові  перевірте свої відповіді, давайте подивимося,
щоб перша Кеті працювала в
КП протягом трьох років і вона
працювала в бухгалтерії
вісім місяців. Причина, по якій вона живе
на роботі, полягає в тому, що
вона не може використовувати всі свої навички та  нова
посада, здається, ідеально підходить,
і наступне питання - це
проблема з подорожами для неї, вона сказала однозначно ні,
тому що у неї немає сім'ї, і
насправді її це дійсно цікавить
, наступне питання, чому вона була
успішною як торговий представник  для
мовної школи вона була успішною,
тому що школа збільшила кількість
реєстрацій, давайте йти далі.
Її короткострокова мета полягає в тому, що вона
хоче розвивати свої навички продажів і
свою довгострокову мету, я  вона хоче
отримати високу посаду в компанії,
що є її найбільшою слабкістю, і
вона зізнається, що призначає зустрічі
в останню хвилину, і останнє це те, що
її мотивація полягає в тому, щоб працювати під тиском,
і вона працює і працює краще під
тиск
добре, я думаю, що вона отримає свою роботу,
звісно, вона, здається, сильний ка
дидат, тому, як я завжди кажу, практика ро
ить ідеальну ро
мову, намагайтеся, і все буде просто чу
ово, добре, хлопці, це кі
ець уроку, сподіваюся побачити вас наступного ра
у  ти до побачення
[музика]
ти